بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الاخ العزيز صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ال سعود ولي العهد ورئيس
مجلس الوزراء في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه الساده اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه
السيدات والساده الحضور السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
بدء اسمحوا لي ان اتقدم بالشكر الجزيل
لخادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز وولي عهده الامير محمد بن
سلمان ال سعود وللشعب السعودي الشقيق
لاستضافه وتنظيم هذه القمه
والشكر موصول للاخ الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون
وللجزائر الشقيقه على حسن ادارتها للقمه
بدورتها السابقه
الحضور الكريم
يسعدني هناك ان ارحب بعوده سوريا الشقيقه
الى مكانها الطبيعي وهي خطوه اكدنا عليها
ودعمناها منذ البدايه
لاعتقادنا باهميتها على طريق اعاده
الاستقرار في المنطقه
ومن منطلق الشعور بالمسؤوليه تجاه كل
اشقائنا في البلدان العربيه نشدد على
اهميه العمل العربي المشترك من اجل احتواء
الخلافات ومن واجبنا هنا الا ندع السودان
الشقيق ينزلق الى اتون الانشقاق والتناحر
الداخلي
ونرحب بمبادرات التي تدعو الى انهاء
الاقتتال هناك
ونامل ان تنجح الجهود لتحقيق الاستقرار في
ليبيا الشقيقه
مثلما نستبشر خيرا باستمرار محاولات تحقيق
السلام في اليمن الشقيق
ونجدد وقوفنا مع اشقائنا في لبنان من اجل
تجاوز الظروف السياسيه والاقتصاديه كما
نشدد على موقف العراق الثابت والمبدئي
ازاء الحق الفلسطيني في الارض والسياده
وباقامه دوله عاصمتها القدس الشريف ولا
يفوتنا هنا ان نذكر العالم ان المقدسات ما
زالت تنتهك هناك بما لا يقبله الضمير
الانساني
نستثمر وجودنا هنا لنعرب عن الترحيب
بالاتفاق بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه وهي خطوه
عمليه دعمها العراق وعمل على تحقيقها
باستثمار النوايا الطيبه من البلدين
الجارين خدمه للاستقرار والازدهار في
المنطقه
ان التفاف العرب حول بعضهم لا ينبغي ان
يفهم على انه انعزال بل يمكن ان يزيدنا
ذلك انفتاحا على جيراننا كعرب مجتمعين
وكدول عربيه منفرده
وانني ادعو الجامعه العربيه الى تطوير
مناهجها نحو بناء تكتل اقتصادي من شانه
تعزيز اقتصادياتنا واستثمار مواردنا
المختلفه بافضل وجه
لقد استطاع الدول عديده ان تبني تكتلات
اقتصاديه ناجحه وهي لا تملك من العناصر
المشتركه بين اعضائها شيئا بل لا تملك لغه
مشتركه حتى لذا يتوجب علينا جميعا ان
نتحرك كل زوايا الترابط والتكامل
الاقتصادي بين بلداننا وعلى هذا المسار
سنستضيف في العراق مؤتمرات عده لوضع الحجر
الاساس لمثل هذا التعاون منها مؤتمر بغداد
للتكامل الاقتصادي والاستقرار الاقليمي
كما تتهيا العاصمه بغداد هذه الايام
لاحتضان مؤتمر طريق التنميه ذلك المشروع
الواعد الذي سيعزز الروابط والمصالح
الجامعه لشعوبنا
وحين نتحدث عن التنميه المستدامه يتوجب
الوقوف عند التغيرات المناخيه وشح المياه
هذا الملف الذي يتطلب منا عملا مشتركا في
ضوء القوانين والاعراف الدوليه لايجاد
حلول جذريه تخفف من الاثار السلبيه لهذا
التحدي الحقيقي
السيدات والساده ان شعوبنا من الشعوب
الشابه وهذه حقيقه تضيف الينا مسؤوليه
حساسه ومن هنا فان افه المخدرات وما
يوازيها من محاولات للتاثير الثقافي
والقيم تتطلب منا موقفا حاسما ينطلق من
التكاتف والتعاون لمكافحه هذه الافه
لقد وقف اخوتكم في العراق وقدموا ابلغ
التضحيات لحمايه العراق والمنطقه والعالم
من خلال تصديهم للهجمه الارهابيه الهمجيه
وذلك الانتصار الذي حققناه يدفعنا قدما
للمضي لبناء بلدنا وتحقيق ما يصبو له
ابناء شعبنا في التنميه والرخاء الاخوه
واصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو اتقدم لكم
جميعا بالدعوه لعقد القمه العربيه لعام 25
في بغداد دار السلام التي تتطلعه لاحتضان
الاشقاء العرب في بلاد الرافدين في الختام
اجدد الشكر للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه لحفاوه الاستقبال وحسن الضيافه
واتمنى لهذه القمه الموفقيه والنجاح لما
فيه مصلحه شعوبنا العربيه وشعوب المنطقه
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات